[Music]
many stories written about sheila
johnson
contain the words first and onlys
sheila is an incredibly wealthy powerful
and philanthropic trailblazer with an
estimated net worth of 750 million
dollars
she's the woman behind black
entertainment television the first
channel for black americans
[Music]
sheila was born in 1949 but due to the
nature of her father's career as a
neurosurgeon
her family moved around a lot johnson's
parents enrolled her in an all-white
school in the early 1950s in kentucky
before desegregation was federally
mandated
she says that due to her fair skin her
third grade classmates thought she was
white
her family moved around some more and
settled in maywood illinois when she was
in fifth grade
the school district required every
student to play an instrument
and she took a particular liking to the
violin
she continued playing the violin and
secured a full scholarship to the
university of illinois to study music
she was the first black student in the
music department as well as the first
black cheerleader at the university
after graduation sheila got married to
robert johnson and they moved to
washington dc
he worked as a lobbyist for the cable tv
industry while sheila taught music at a
private school she signed for the
company's very first loan in 1979
and was extremely vital in getting the
network started
the company made history as the first
african-american controlled company
listed on the new york stock exchange
when it was listed in 1991
the johnsons took bet private in 1998
for 1.3 billion dollars and in 2001
viacom bought them out for 2.9 billion
dollars
in 2002 sheila and her husband parted
ways personally
and professionally sheila told forbes
she sold her shares in viacom and has
since invested in hotels in florida and
virginia
real estate and horses she founded
salamander hospitality in 2005 and
oversees a growing portfolio of
luxury properties she continues to
champion black voices and was executive
producer of lee
daniel's film the butler which followed
a former slave's time working in the
white house
and fun fact she's the only black woman
to own stakes in three professional
sports teams
the wnba mystics the nba wizards
and the nhl capitals thanks to sheila's
many
firsts and onlys she's shown what's
possible for so many black americans
she continues to champion and empower
the people around her
all while continuing to build her empire
you